Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Never, perhaps, has there been a more perfect example of the completeness of good fortune, from his first appearance on the field of battle to his final and heroic death. To Custer alone it was reserved to join a romantic life of perfect success to a death of perfect heroism, to unite the splendors of Austerlitz and Thermopylae, to charge like Murat, to die like Leonidas. Throughout all time and the whole civilized world, wherever the accounts of the war are read in the glorious annals of our common country,
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、享受无广告体验、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。从他第一次出现在战场上到他最后英勇牺牲，或许再也没有比他那圆满的幸运更完美的例子了。只有卡斯特（Custer）才注定将浪漫的完美成功人生与完美的英雄之死结合在一起，将奥斯特利茨（Austerlitz）和温泉关（Thermopylae）的辉煌融为一体，像缪拉（Murat）一样冲锋，像列奥尼达（Leonidas）一样牺牲。在整个文明世界的漫长岁月中，无论在何处阅读我们共同国家光荣史册中关于这场战争的记载，
there will be no brighter page than that which relates the daring deeds of George A. Custer. Ohio is proud to claim him as her son and to exalt in his name. But he was the representative of the nation, and defended her flag, and the nation enrolls him among her heroes. But her limits are too circumscribed to bound his fame. The time in which he lived claims him as the new Leonidas, with his noble kin slain in that wild thermopylae of the West. So, stirring words, Dominic. Incredibly stirring, Tom. And they featured in an article written by Judge Richard Verhees in the Ohio Archaeological and Historical Culturally in 1906. Yeah.
都不会有比讲述乔治·A·卡斯特（George A. Custer）英勇事迹的那一页更灿烂的了。俄亥俄州为能称他为自己的儿子并以他的名字为荣而感到自豪。但他不仅是国家的代表，他捍卫了国家的旗帜，国家也将他列入英雄之列。但国家的疆界太狭窄，无法限制他的名声。他所处的时代称他为新的列奥尼达，他那高贵的亲属在西部那狂野的温泉关中牺牲。那么，多米尼克（Dominic），真是令人振奋的文字。汤姆（Tom），确实令人难以置信地振奋。它们出自理查德·沃希斯（Richard Voorhees）法官于1906年在《俄亥俄考古与历史季刊》上发表的一篇文章。是的。
But the good judge was actually ripping off. Oh, no. Almost word for word, Frederick Whittaker, because I actually quoted a bit of this way back in episode one, a long time ago. So long ago that I've forgotten. Yeah. So Frederick Whittaker, a writer who Custer had met in 1875 when he was in New York, you know, dabbling in the stock exchange and all that. Yeah. In the new offices of the Galaxy, which was the magazine that Custer was writing, you know, right the way up to his
但这位好法官实际上是在剽窃。哦，不。几乎逐字逐句地抄袭了弗雷德里克·惠特克（Frederick Whittaker），因为我在很久以前的第一集里确实引用过其中的一部分。时间太久了，我都忘了。是的。弗雷德里克·惠特克是一位作家，卡斯特在1875年身处纽约时曾见过他，当时他（卡斯特）正在涉足证券交易所之类的事务。是的。在《银河》（Galaxy）杂志的新办公室里，那是卡斯特一直撰稿的杂志，你知道，一直写到他
departure for the Little Bighorn. And after his death at the Battle of the Little Bighorn, Frederick Whittaker pumped this out, a two-volume biography of him. So it kind of came out while, you know, the coyotes were feasting still on the carrion at Little Bighorn. Oh, no. And Whittaker thought Custer was brilliant. Yeah, clearly. He was a great man, one of the few really great men that America has produced.
出发前往小大角河（Little Bighorn）。在他于小大角河战役中阵亡后，弗雷德里克·惠特克就推出了这本关于他的两卷本传记。所以它出版的时候，你知道，郊狼还在小大角河啃食腐肉呢。哦，不。惠特克认为卡斯特非常出色。是的，很明显。他是一位伟人，是美国培养出的少数几位真正的伟人之一。
But you can see why Everhuruis would be all over that, because Ohio is Custer's home state. Custer's home state. Yeah. And Voorhees, interestingly, is a Democratic Party hack who had served in the Civil War, as Custer had, but then had backed President Andrew Johnson over Reconstruction, basically against Reconstruction, as Custer had.
但你可以看出为什么沃希斯会如此推崇他，因为俄亥俄州是卡斯特的家乡。卡斯特的家乡。是的。有趣的是，沃希斯是一个民主党的政客，他曾像卡斯特一样在内战中服役，但后来在重建问题上支持安德鲁·约翰逊（Andrew Johnson）总统，基本上是反对重建，正如卡斯特所做的那样。
So it's an example of the way in which Custer's fame is politicised. But actually, Custer then transcends that, doesn't he? He does. At first, he's a political figure, but actually quite soon after that, he becomes a genuine national folk hero. And all that stuff about an American thermopoly and the new Leonidas and stuff, that sort of is the image of the little bighorn, even when we were growing up, Tom, in the 70s. Absolutely. I can't remember. We've done so many episodes. Did we mention the Lady Bird book? We did, six years ago when we first started this.
所以这是一个卡斯特的名声被政治化的例子。但实际上，卡斯特后来超越了这一点，不是吗？确实如此。起初，他是一个政治人物，但很快之后，他就成为了一个真正的民族民间英雄。所有关于美国温泉关和新列奥尼达之类的说法，即使在我们70年代成长的时候，汤姆，那也是小大角河的形象。绝对是。我不记得了。我们做了这么多集。我们提到过《瓢虫》（Lady Bird）那本书吗？我们提过，六年前我们刚开始做这个节目的时候。
Which on the cover has a long-haired custer surrounded by blue-coated members of the 7th Cavalry, crowded on a hill with the stars and stripes flying overhead. Fighting manfully. All of which, as we will probably see over the course of the next two episodes, that's probably not what happened at all. But I think the comparison with Lenidas is fair to the extent that Custer's fame is due to the fact that he and all his men die. And it's not very often that that happens. Generally, people who fight battles are famous
封面上是一个长发的卡斯特，被第七骑兵团身穿蓝色制服的成员包围，挤在一座小山上，头顶飘扬着星条旗。英勇地战斗着。所有这些，正如我们可能在接下来的两集里看到的那样，那可能根本不是发生的事情。但我认为与列奥尼达的比较是公平的，因为卡斯特的名声归功于他和他的所有部下都阵亡了。这种情况并不常见。通常，打仗的人出名
because they win it, and certainly not because they die and everyone with them. So this is what we're looking at today. It's the Battle of the Little Bighorn. And does it deserve the mythic status that it has and more importantly i suppose to what extent can the myth be mapped onto what we know about what might actually have happened well that's the fascinating thing because it's so often in this podcast we come up against the unknowability of the past but this has a real sense of mystery because of course at the climactic moment, you know, everybody dies. Everybody survives.
是因为他们赢了，当然不是因为他们死了，而且所有人都和他们一起死了。所以这就是我们今天要看的内容。这是小大角河战役。它是否配得上它所拥有的神话地位，更重要的是，我认为在多大程度上可以将这个神话映射到我们所知道的可能实际发生的事情上？嗯，这就是迷人的地方，因为在这个播客中，我们经常遇到过去不可知的问题，但这确实有一种神秘感，因为当然，在最关键的时刻，你知道，每个人都死了。每个人都幸存了下来。
Yeah. Well, certainly on the American side, of course, there are a lot of Lakota or Cheyenne warriors who are fighting at it and who do give reports. But again, the question of how far they are to be trusted is a fascinating topic that we will explore. Exactly. So we ended last time on the 22nd of june custer had marched out and he was in preoccupied form i think it's fair to say and if you remember from last time his orders are vague they are to kind of drive the natives if he finds them to drive them up towards general terry who will be advancing from the south.
是的。嗯，当然在美方，确实有很多拉科塔（Lakota）或夏延（Cheyenne）战士在战斗，他们确实提供了报告。但同样，他们的话在多大程度上值得信任是一个迷人的话题，我们将探讨。没错。所以我们上次结束于6月22日，卡斯特已经出发了，我想说他当时心事重重，如果你还记得上次的内容，他的命令很模糊，如果他发现当地人，就驱赶他们，把他们赶向将从南方推进的特里（Terry）将军。
But if he has the chance, he basically has carte blanche to go for it and to attack. And everybody expects that he will. General Terry's men think, when we get there, Custer will have won the day. And the only real question is whether any Indians will escape. We keep saying Indians, actually, Tom, have degenerated. I just think it's easier because, I mean, our perspective is, of course, that of the Americans, because it's the Americans who generally write the accounts. Yeah, who tell the story. Although, as we said, we do have Native American oral accounts, by and large,
但如果他有机会，他基本上有全权去行动并进行攻击。每个人都期待他会这样做。特里将军的人认为，当我们到达那里时，卡斯特已经赢得了胜利。唯一真正的问题是是否有印第安人会逃脱。我们一直在说印第安人，实际上，汤姆，已经退化了。我只是觉得这样更容易，因为，我的意思是，我们的视角当然是美国人的视角，因为通常是美国人写下这些记录。是的，讲述故事的人。虽然正如我们所说，我们确实有美洲原住民的口述记录，但总的来说，
our sources are American. And so it seems sensible, I think, rather than say Lakota or Cheyenne or whatever over and over again to say Indians. Yeah. I mean, obviously, let people understand that we. Yeah, we know they're not from India. We do understand. And we're conscious of the political connotations we use in the term. Yeah. So they raise their teepees. They've been moving around, as we said last time. They're always looking for water. They're always looking for bison. And they raise their teepees on the west bank of a river that they know is the greasy grass, but that we call the Little Bighorn in the afternoon of the 24th of June. About a thousand teepees there in semicircles.
我们的来源是美国人。所以我觉得与其一遍又一遍地说拉科塔或夏延或其他什么，不如说印第安人更明智。是的。我的意思是，显然，让人们明白我们。是的，我们知道他们不是来自印度。我们确实明白。而且我们意识到我们使用这个术语时的政治内涵。是的。所以他们搭起了帐篷。正如我们上次所说，他们一直在四处移动。他们一直在寻找水源。他们一直在寻找野牛。他们在6月24日下午在一条他们知道是“油腻草地”（Greasy Grass），但我们称之为小大角河的河西岸搭起了帐篷。那里大约有一千个半圆形的帐篷。
Everybody says this is the most gorgeous spot. So Nathaniel Philbrick in his book with the, shall we say, the slight hyperbole for which works of American nonfiction are renowned, one of the most hauntingly beautiful valleys in the world, he says. Do you think that's true, Tom? You've been there. It is very beautiful, but it's also quite hard to get a handle on it. You know, it's full of ravines and bluffs and things as well. So should I just give a, I think it's really, really difficult even when you have a book in front of you with a map or video, let alone a podcast. You're going to give us a little geography lesson, are you? No, I'm not, but I'm just the
每个人都说这是最美的地方。所以纳撒尼尔·菲尔布里克（Nathaniel Philbrick）在他的书中，用我们称之为美国非虚构作品中常见的轻微夸张手法说，这是世界上最令人难忘的美丽山谷之一。你觉得是真的吗，汤姆？你去过那里。它非常美丽，但也相当难以把握。你知道，它也充满了沟壑和悬崖之类的东西。所以我应该给一个，我觉得即使你面前有一本书，上面有地图或视频，更不用说播客了，这真的非常非常困难。你要给我们上一堂简短的地理课吗？不，我不是，但我只是
setting where the village is, that it's by the Bighorn River and the village is on the side where the plain is, obviously. So they're open flats. There are trees and undergrowth that run along the side of the river. And on the opposite side of the river, there are bluffs. And it's quite difficult to get down from those bluffs to the river. And there are certain fording points. And those bluffs are scored by ravines. So it is possible if you are, say, a Lakota warrior to climb up that ravine and not be seen. Equally, it is quite difficult if you're on a horse to come down it. There are only certain approaches down to the river, so that's important. And also to say that the Little Bighorn is fed by a creek and that the 7th Cavalry, as it
村庄所在的环境，它在大角河边，村庄显然在平原那一侧。所以那是开阔的平地。河边有树木和灌木丛。在河的对岸，有悬崖。从那些悬崖下到河边相当困难。而且有特定的渡口。那些悬崖被沟壑切割。所以如果你是一个拉科塔战士，爬上那个沟壑而不被发现是有可能的。同样，如果你骑着马下来也相当困难。下到河边只有特定的路径，所以这很重要。还要说小大角河是由一条小溪汇入的，第七骑兵团在
is approaching the Bighorn, is coming down that creek. Yeah, exactly right, Tom. So just try and keep that in your head. So it's a beautiful spot on the banks of the river, as you say. There are now about 7,000 to 8,000 Native Americans in the village. Of them, and there are obviously lots of women and children, so about 1,800 of them, maybe 2,000 are warriors. But obviously the presence of women and children very, very important. Of course. As it was at the Weshita. Which people will remember, yeah.
接近大角河时，正沿着那条小溪走。是的，完全正确，汤姆。所以试着把它记在脑子里。所以正如你所说，这是河岸边一个美丽的地方。村里现在大约有7000到8000名美洲原住民。其中，显然有很多妇女和儿童，所以大约有1800人，也许2000人是战士。但显然妇女和儿童的存在非常非常重要。当然。就像在沃希塔（Washita）一样。人们会记得的，是的。
Where Custer rounded up women and children and that played a huge part in his victory there. Exactly. Now, the interesting thing is that it's not just non-treaty, anti-treaty Indians who are in the village. There are lots of Lakota who have actually come from the reservation. And here is another sign of the unanticipated consequences of President Grant's sort of sinister plan to force a war on the Lakota. When they had tried to buy the black hills loads of people had flocked into these big meetings to discuss you know to put pressure on them not to sell you know the chiefs not to sell so that population in the reservation had really swollen as it would anyway over the winter and there's enormous pressure for food and resources and there's not enough food to go
卡斯特在那里围捕了妇女和儿童，这在他那里的胜利中起了巨大的作用。没错。现在，有趣的是，村里不仅有非条约、反条约的印第安人。还有很多实际上从保留地来的拉科塔人。这是格兰特（Grant）总统那种强迫拉科塔人开战的险恶计划所带来的不可预见后果的另一个迹象。当他们试图购买黑山（Black Hills）时，大量的人涌入这些大型会议进行讨论，你知道，向他们施压，不要出售，你知道，酋长们不要出售，所以保留地的人口确实膨胀了，无论如何，冬天过后，对食物和资源的需求压力巨大，而且没有足够的食物
around now normally what would happen is that as soon as was possible warriors would go out enormous pressure for food and resources and there's not enough food to go around. Now normally what would happen is that as soon as was possible warriors would go out and hunt buffalo to make up for the shortfall and they would use guns from the agency but because Grant's administration know that war is coming they have banned the agents on the reservation from giving out guns. So they can't go hunting. And that is why, almost in kind of desperation, they flock to Sitting Bull's village, which means that in due course, Custer and co. will be facing far greater numbers
分发。现在通常会发生的情况是，只要有可能，战士们就会出去，对食物和资源的需求压力巨大，而且没有足够的食物分发。现在通常会发生的情况是，只要有可能，战士们就会出去猎杀野牛以弥补短缺，他们会使用代理机构提供的枪支，但因为格兰特政府知道战争即将来临，他们禁止保留地的代理人发放枪支。所以他们不能去打猎。这就是为什么，几乎出于一种绝望，他们涌向坐牛（Sitting Bull）的村庄，这意味着到适当的时候，卡斯特和他的同伙将面临远比他们可能预想的要多得多的人数。
than they had possibly envisaged. But also the victory at the Rosebud, which Crazy Horse had won over General Crook's army, which we talked about in the previous episode, that also will have had an immense resonance, won't it? Totally. I mean, basically the sense, you know, if you want to have fun, come and join us. Of course. And a sense of invulnerability.
但还有疯马（Crazy Horse）在罗斯巴德（Rosebud）战役中战胜克鲁克（Crook）将军军队的胜利，我们在上一集谈到过，那也会产生巨大的共鸣，不是吗？完全是。我的意思是，基本上那种感觉，你知道，如果你想找乐子，就加入我们。当然。还有一种无懈可击的感觉。
That this spring, uniquely, it's all happening. We're going to be in a great position. Everybody is going. It's such a large village now. I mean, most historians say this is one of the largest gatherings of Native Americans in the entire history of the Great Plains. Because normally, they're so nomadic, so scattered, 8,000 people in one place. And the warriors think no one would attack such a large village. of course the american units are not enormous there are like a thousand people here a thousand people there we outnumber them by such a
今年春天，独特的是，一切都在发生。我们将处于一个很好的位置。每个人都去了。现在这是一个如此大的村庄。我的意思是，大多数历史学家说这是大平原历史上美洲原住民最大规模的集会之一。因为通常，他们是如此游牧，如此分散，8000人聚集在一个地方。战士们认为没有人会攻击这样一个大的村庄。当然，美国部队并不庞大，这里有一千人，那里有一千人，我们的人数比他们多出这么多
big margin there's no way they're going to attack us they're still celebrating their victory at the rosebud they've been holding victory feasts and dances and kind of you know storytelling sessions and having a great laugh for days there's a wonderful account by a guy called wooden leg wooden leg died in 1940 so i mean that gives you a sense of it's amazing isn't it yeah incredible he died during the second world war and he gave his recollections in 1903 and he i think he was very young at the time. And he said, you know, my friends and I were just interested in basically chasing girls. Chasing the girls. All that kind of thing.
巨大的优势，他们不可能攻击我们，他们还在庆祝他们在罗斯巴德的胜利，他们一直在举行胜利宴会和舞蹈，还有你知道，讲故事的环节，并且连续几天开怀大笑，有一个叫“木腿”（Wooden Leg）的人的精彩记录，“木腿”死于1940年，所以我的意思是这让你有一种感觉，这很神奇，不是吗？是的，不可思议，他死于第二次世界大战期间，他在1903年提供了他的回忆，我想他当时非常年轻。他说，你知道，我和我的朋友们基本上只对追女孩感兴趣。追女孩。所有那类事情。
Oh my God, Tom. That was one of the most terrifying things that's ever happened in the history. The rest is history. Yeah. That's, what was it? You know, the guys who went around in the pickup truck. Dukes of Hazzard. I was about to say, is it the Dukes of Hazzard?
天哪，汤姆。那是历史上发生过的最可怕的事情之一。《历史的余味》。是的。那是，那是什么？你知道，开着皮卡车到处跑的家伙。哈扎德公爵（Dukes of Hazzard）。我正要说，是《哈扎德公爵》吗？
Yeah, it's the Dukes of Hazzard. I can't believe the Dukes of Hazzard have appeared in this story. Yes. And the general sense is, you know know we're out of the white man's country no one can touch us we're going to have a great laugh there are lots of games for the children the only person who really has a sense of foreboding is of course sitting bull sitting bull goes up that evening sunset the 24th of June. He goes up a sort of a knoll and he leaves gifts for the great spirit, Wacken Tanker, a buffalo robe, a pipe and some tobacco. And he does this sort of prayer and he says, please look after the tribe, guard us against calamities. Maybe because he's been around a bit, he knows the Americans are not going away.
是的，是《哈扎德公爵》。我不敢相信《哈扎德公爵》出现在这个故事里。是的。总的感觉是，你知道，我们离开了白人的国家，没有人能碰我们，我们要好好笑一场，有很多给孩子们玩的游戏，唯一真正有预感的人当然是坐牛，坐牛那天晚上，6月24日日落时分。他走上了一个小山丘，他为伟大的精神，瓦坎坦卡（Wakan Tanka），留下了礼物，一件野牛皮长袍，一个烟斗和一些烟草。他做了这种祈祷，他说，请照顾部落，保护我们免受灾难。也许因为他经历过一些事情，他知道美国人不会离开。
Well, also he's been given a vision, hasn't he? He has been given a vision, of course, Tom. I was discounting the vision. Well, also, I mean, he's in a good deal of pain because he's had bits of his arms removed. God almighty, yeah. So there's a description of him at the Battle of the Rosebud, and it's basically his arms. He can't use his arms because they're covered in blood. Yeah, he's not really fighting. Now, meanwhile, of course, that very day, Custer is coming. Custer has about 660 men. 30 of them or so are officers. About 40 of them, 45 of them are guides of various kinds or scouts. The majority of the enlisted men who are actually, without being mean to them, pretty useless.
嗯，而且他得到了一个幻象，不是吗？他确实得到了一个幻象，当然，汤姆。我刚才忽略了那个幻象。嗯，而且，我的意思是，他非常痛苦，因为他的手臂被切掉了一些。天哪，是的。所以有关于他在罗斯巴德战役中的描述，基本上是他的手臂。他不能使用他的手臂，因为它们被血覆盖了。是的，他并没有真正战斗。现在，与此同时，当然，就在那天，卡斯特来了。卡斯特大约有660人。其中大约30人是军官。大约40人，45人是各种向导或侦察兵。大多数应征士兵，实际上，没有恶意，相当没用。
Well, so about 30% have never once fired a carbine is the estimate. Yeah. I mean, bonkers. He is dressed, of course, in his finery, in his buckskin jacket, in his big hat. He wears the sort of red scarf and his neck, the red kind of cravat that he had worn in the Civil War. Quite a lot of them are wearing straw hats. Yeah. So there's a guy on the Yellowstone who's been selling them straw hats.
嗯，所以大约30%的人从来没有开过卡宾枪，这是估计。是的。我的意思是，疯了。他当然穿着他的盛装，穿着他的鹿皮夹克，戴着他的大帽子。他戴着那种红色的围巾和他的脖子，他在内战中戴的那种红色领结。他们中相当多的人戴着草帽。是的。所以黄石河上有一个家伙一直在卖给他们草帽。
And one of the guys who's wearing a straw hat is Major Reno. Straw hats is not the look, is it really? So they're not wearing blue coats. No. By and large, too hot. Yeah. Most of them, I mean, unless you're wearing buckskin like Custer and Tom Custer and so on, are wearing white shirts.
其中一个戴草帽的家伙是雷诺（Reno）少校。草帽不是那种造型，是吗？所以他们没有穿蓝色外套。不。总的来说，太热了。是的。他们大多数人，我的意思是，除非你像卡斯特和汤姆·卡斯特（Tom Custer）等人那样穿着鹿皮，否则都穿着白衬衫。
Yeah. Now he is in a hurry, Custer, as we said last time. He now knows he's not really going to get back before the Democratic Convention because that actually opens in, I think, three days time. But with luck, he might just be able to get back before the 4th of July celebration in Philadelphia. At the very least, if he's quick, the news of his victory will be able to get back and he will be the star. He will be the talk of the centennial exhibition. And that would be a very big thing for him with his political career and his kind of financial hopes. And of course, he needs to go on that lecture tour to pay off the debts that he has to these various financiers. So he's pushing his men that June the 24th. So
是的。现在他很匆忙，卡斯特，正如我们上次所说。他现在知道他真的不会在民主党全国代表大会之前赶回去，因为那实际上在，我想，三天后开幕。但运气好的话，他可能刚好能在费城7月4日的庆祝活动之前赶回去。至少，如果他快一点，他胜利的消息就能传回去，他将成为明星。他将成为百年博览会谈论的焦点。这对他的政治生涯和他那种经济希望来说将是一件大事。当然，他需要去进行那次巡回演讲，以偿还他欠这些各种金融家的债务。所以他在6月24日那天催促他的部下。所以
the day that the Lakota established their camp, Custer has pushed his men 28 miles through the dust. The sun is beating down now. They are very bedraggled and knackered. They have great problems with the pack train. So stuff keeps falling off the back of the mules. But also mules don't go as fast as horses. No. I mean, I'll tell you one thing. He's probably thinking, thank God we didn't bring those Gatling guns because they really have slowed us down. Yeah.
拉科塔人建立营地的那一天，卡斯特在尘土中催促他的部下走了28英里。太阳现在正炙烤着。他们非常衣衫褴褛，筋疲力尽。他们在驮运队方面有很大的问题。所以东西不断地从骡子背上掉下来。但骡子也没有马跑得快。不。我的意思是，我告诉你一件事。他可能在想，谢天谢地我们没有带那些加特林机枪，因为它们真的拖慢了我们的速度。是的。
They are now following what they think of the trails through the Rosebud Valley. It is obvious that there are lots of different trails. Of course there are because so many people are joining the village. And some of the scouts, we talked in a previous episode about bloody knife the guy who'd been bullied by uh the lakota tom yeah by gall wasn't he yeah by gall the flash the flashman of the lakota yeah and he is among the scouts so bloody knife says to custer that evening it looks like there are going to be a lot of you you know, this is a big group of people. And word of this gets around.
他们现在正沿着他们认为是罗斯巴德山谷的小径走。很明显有很多不同的小径。当然有，因为有这么多人加入村庄。而且一些侦察兵，我们在前一集谈到过“血腥刀”（Bloody Knife），那个被拉科塔人欺负的家伙，汤姆，是的，被加尔（Gall）欺负，不是吗？是的，被加尔，拉科塔的闪电侠（Flashman），是的，他在侦察兵中，所以“血腥刀”那天晚上对卡斯特说，看起来会有很多人，你知道，这是一个很大的群体。关于这个的消息传开了。
So at one point, Custer's orderly, John Burtman, who we mentioned a few times, hears Custer say, there are a lot of them. There are more of them than we figured. And Burtman says slightly anxiously, not too many of them to lick though. And Custer immediately smiles. Well, we'll get them. Yee-haw. Yeah.
所以有一次，卡斯特的传令官约翰·伯特曼（John Burtman），我们提到过几次，听到卡斯特说，他们有很多。他们比我们估计的要多。伯特曼稍微焦虑地说，不过没多到打不过。卡斯特立刻笑了。嗯，我们会抓住他们的。耶。是的。
What the seventh can't lick, the US Army couldn't lick. Yeah. And he absolutely, now whether he's just saying that or whether he believes it. I'm sure he believes it. I think he believes it. But Bloody Knife, I mean, he thinks he's going to die, doesn't he? I shall not see the sun. Yeah.
第七骑兵团打不过的，美国陆军也打不过。是的。他绝对，现在不管他只是说说而已还是他真的相信。我相信他相信。我想他相信。但“血腥刀”，我的意思是，他认为他会死，不是吗？我将看不到太阳。是的。
He says. Exactly as you would expect somebody to say in a Western. And he does say it. Or somebody in a kind of Homeric epic, Tom. Yeah. It has some of those qualities, doesn't it? Well, as we will see, there is an element of Greek tragedy to Bloody Knife's fate. Definitely.
他说。正如你所期望的某人在西部片中所说的那样。他确实说了。或者像荷马史诗中的某个人，汤姆。是的。它确实有一些那样的特质，不是吗？嗯，正如我们将看到的，“血腥刀”的命运有一种希腊悲剧的成分。绝对是。
So that evening they rest. Some of the lieutenants, this is a very buried detail, Tom, I don't know if you spotted this, but they are singing the doxology. I did. I don't actually know what the dox, but they are singing the doxology. I did. I don't actually know what the doxology is. What is the doxology? It's kind of hymn. It's hymns.
所以那天晚上他们休息了。一些中尉，这是一个非常隐蔽的细节，汤姆，我不知道你有没有发现这个，但他们在唱《三位一体颂》（Doxology）。我发现了。我实际上不知道什么是《三位一体颂》，但他们在唱《三位一体颂》。我发现了。我实际上不知道什么是《三位一体颂》。什么是《三位一体颂》？这是一种赞美诗。是赞美诗。
Yeah. I mean, you sing it in a hymnic form. Right. So Custer's just staring into space. He's just exhausted and worried, anxious, in a hurry. But probably not about the battle. No. I mean, just to reiterate that, he's worried about his financial and political prospects.
是的。我的意思是，你用赞美诗的形式唱它。对。所以卡斯特只是盯着虚空。他只是筋疲力尽，担心，焦虑，匆忙。但可能不是关于战斗。不。我的意思是，重申一下，他担心他的经济和政治前景。
Yeah. And at nine o'clock that night, 24th, so this is only a few hours after Sitting Bull has gone up and done that prayer, some Crow Scouts gallop into the camp and say, amazing news. We have found what we are certain is the principal Lakota trail, and it is leading out of the Rosebud Valley to the west towards the Little Bighorn. So brilliant. Now Custer, of course, doesn't have to attack. He could just kind of shadow them and push them up towards General Terry. But there's no doubt in anybody's mind that when he comes to the crunch, he's going to go for it. He's a striker in on goal, Tom. He's going to take the shot.
是的。那天晚上九点，24日，所以这只是坐牛上去做那个祈祷几个小时后，一些克罗族（Crow）侦察兵骑马冲进营地，说，惊人的消息。我们发现了我们确定是主要的拉科塔小径，它正从罗斯巴德山谷向西通往小大角河。太棒了。现在卡斯特，当然，不必攻击。他可以只是跟踪他们，把他们赶向特里将军。但毫无疑问，当他面临紧要关头时，他会去攻击。他是一个冲向球门的射手，汤姆。他会射门的。
Yeah, he's a goal hanger. Very good. That's what he does. So it takes him 20 minutes to make up his mind. At 9.20, he says to the head of the scouts, who's a guy called Lieutenant Varnum, or Lieutenant Varnum, as he would be called in the wilds of the West, of the Old West. He says, go back with the scouts.
是的，他是一个守门员。非常好。这就是他所做的。所以他花了20分钟才下定决心。9点20分，他对侦察兵的首领说，那是一个叫瓦纳姆（Varnum）中尉的家伙，或者叫瓦纳姆中尉，正如他在旧西部的荒野中会被称呼的那样。他说，带着侦察兵回去。
There's a prominent position you should be able to see. We will will follow i will bring up the troops you know let's let's do this now so we're on the evening of the 24th his plan is he will march overnight then on the 25th they will rest and they will attack just before dawn on the 26th and from various angles as they had done at the washita exactly he will do his old trick that worked before it worked before the washita the very controversial battle or massacre depending on your viewpoint and so his troops will be very well rested because although they will have done the midnight march they will have the whole of the day and the night to rest, and then they'll attack the following day at dawn.
有一个突出的位置你应该能看到。我们将跟随，我会带上部队，你知道，我们现在就做这个。所以我们是在24日晚上，他的计划是他将连夜行军，然后在25日他们将休息，他们将在26日黎明前攻击，从各个角度，就像他们在沃希塔所做的那样，完全一样，他将使用他以前的老把戏，以前奏效过，在沃希塔奏效过，那场非常有争议的战斗或大屠杀，取决于你的观点，所以他的部队将得到很好的休息，因为虽然他们会进行午夜行军，但他们将有一整天和晚上的时间休息，然后他们将在第二天黎明攻击。
That is the plan. But obviously that requires the Indians not to realise that the 7th Cavalry are approaching. Of course. So he pushes them overnight on the midnight march. I mean, the details of it are pretty grue mean, they're pretty gruelling even to read. They do 12 miles and they stop. They have coffee, then they do five more miles.
这就是计划。但显然这需要印第安人没有意识到第七骑兵团正在接近。当然。所以他连夜催促他们进行午夜行军。我的意思是，细节相当令人毛骨悚然，我的意思是，即使读起来也相当令人筋疲力尽。他们走了12英里，然后停下来。他们喝了咖啡，然后又走了5英里。
Then they stop again. Then they do another 12 miles to get down to the river and they halt just before daylight on the 25th. So thank goodness they are knackered, but they should be able to rest for the day and for the evening and then attack the following day. So it's dawn now on the 25th of June. At that point, Lieutenant Varnum, the head of the scouts,
然后他们又停下来。然后他们又走了12英里到达河边，他们在25日天亮前停了下来。所以谢天谢地他们筋疲力尽，但他们应该能够休息一天和晚上，然后在第二天攻击。所以现在是6月25日黎明。在那一点上，瓦纳姆中尉，侦察兵的首领，
sends some scouts back. He says the crows have seen a massive village, a tremendous village on the Little Bighorn. Custer goes ahead, leaving his men behind. He goes up to a sort of spot called the crow's nest. So it's about nine o'clock now on the Sunday morning, the 25th. Then he looks out and he actually, he can't see the village. He's kind of squinting.
派回了一些侦察兵。他说克罗族人看到了一个巨大的村庄，小大角河上一个巨大的村庄。卡斯特走在前面，把他的部下留在后面。他走到一个叫“乌鸦巢”（Crow's Nest）的地方。所以现在是25日星期天早上九点左右。然后他向外看，他实际上，他看不到村庄。他有点眯着眼睛。
Partly because the spurs of the bluffs are sticking out. Oh, in the way. Exactly. But the scouts say, no, no, no, it's absolutely there. I think it's important that he can't see it because he doesn't really have a sense of the size. How big it is. Yeah.
部分原因是悬崖的支脉伸了出来。哦，挡住了。完全正确。但侦察兵说，不，不，不，它绝对在那里。我认为他看不到它很重要，因为他并没有真正感觉到规模。它有多大。是的。
Yeah. One of the chief scouts is a guy called Mitch Boyer or Boyer. I don't know how you pronounce his name. He says to him, General, if you don't find more Indians in that valley than you ever saw together, then you can hang me. And Custer, who's feeling a bit of pressure, the pressure of the haste, he snaps at him and he says it would do a damn sight of good to hang you now, wouldn't it? And other people are surprised because Custer never swears. It's the first time they've heard him use the word damn, actually. It's not because he's worried that he's going to be beaten, that there are too many of them for him.
是的。首席侦察兵之一是一个叫米奇·博耶（Mitch Boyer）或博耶的家伙。我不知道你怎么发他的名字。他对他说，将军，如果你在那个山谷里发现的印第安人没有你见过的任何时候加起来那么多，那你就把我吊死。而卡斯特，他感到有点压力，匆忙的压力，他对他厉声说，现在把你吊死会很有用，不是吗？其他人很惊讶，因为卡斯特从不骂人。实际上，这是他们第一次听到他用“该死”（damn）这个词。这不是因为他担心他会被打败，因为他们对他来说太多了。
Because, in fact, Bloody Knife says to him, you know, there may be enough Sue there to keep us fighting two or three days. And Custer says, dismissively, kind of chuckles and says, I guess we'll have to get through them in one day. Yeah. You know, Custer is in a hurry. He thinks it can be done. His only anxiety is that they'll split, they'll scatter. He'll miss out on his victory. Totally. Now, of course, at that point, he's planning to wait so everyone can rest. But first of all, the crows say, we've seen Lakotas kind of on the horizon. We think they may have spotted us. You know, we should attack right away. We can't afford to wait. They will know.
因为，事实上，“血腥刀”对他说，你知道，那里可能有足够的苏族人让我们打两三天。卡斯特不屑一顾地轻笑说，我想我们得在一天内解决他们。是的。你知道，卡斯特很匆忙。他认为这可以做到。他唯一的焦虑是他们会分裂，他们会散开。他会错过他的胜利。完全是。现在，当然，在那一点上，他计划等待，以便每个人都能休息。但首先，克罗族人说，我们在地平线上看到了拉科塔人。我们认为他们可能已经发现了我们。你知道，我们应该马上攻击。我们等不起。他们会知道的。
But then Tom Custer, his brother, says, there's been a bit of a mishap. One of the mules dropped its load. The load kind of fell off, and the biscuit's hardtack fell on the ground. And when we went back to get it, we found some cheyenne kind of scrabbling around eating the biscuits and we've scared them off but clearly they're going to go back to this big camp and say that there are soldiers in the vicinity and at that point custer makes up his mind we're not going to rest crack on we just have to do it now now i think this is actually it's one thing that i think most of the books that i've read don't probably bring out enough. How tired they are. They must be shattered.
但后来汤姆·卡斯特，他的兄弟，说，出了一点小差错。其中一头骡子掉了它的负载。负载掉下来了，饼干硬饼干掉在地上。当我们回去拿它时，我们发现一些夏延人在那里乱抓乱吃饼干，我们把他们吓跑了，但很明显他们会回到这个大营地，说附近有士兵，在那一点上，卡斯特下定了决心，我们不休息了，继续前进，我们现在就得做。现在我认为这实际上是，我认为我读过的大多数书可能没有充分体现的一点。他们有多累。他们一定筋疲力尽了。
Yeah. Of course, adrenaline will later course through their veins. They'll be all excited, but they must feel, their legs must feel like lead after walking for- Well, Dominic, as an old Great Plains hand, I can tell you, you don't want to be scrabbling over the scree and the scrub. Not for all hours. Even a hardy veteran of nighttime walks like me. Right. Is that what Great Plains veterans say? Yeah.
是的。当然，肾上腺素稍后会流过他们的血管。他们会很兴奋，但他们一定感觉，他们的腿在走了之后一定感觉像铅一样——嗯，多米尼克，作为一个大平原的老手，我可以告诉你，你不想在碎石和灌木丛上乱爬。不是所有时间。即使是像我这样的夜间行走坚韧老手。对。大平原老手是这么说的吗？是的。
It's tough. Okay. Crikey. Well, it's great to have somebody on the show who really understands that. Yeah. You've walked the terrain though, haven't you, Tom? I've walked the terrain. You know the ground. I've walked the really understands. Yeah. You've walked the terrain though, haven't you, Tom? I've walked the terrain. You know the ground.
这很艰难。哎呀。好吧，节目里有真正理解这一点的人真是太好了。是的。你走过那片地形，不是吗，汤姆？我走过那片地形。你知道那片土地。我走过那片地形。你了解那片土地。
I've walked the bluffs. Yeah. I've walked the gulches. Okay. Rattler Creek. Surely they're all called like Gobbler's Gulch or something like that, aren't they? Yeah, that kind of thing. Okay.
我走过悬崖。是的。我走过峡谷。好的。响尾蛇溪（Rattler Creek）。它们肯定都叫什么“吞食者峡谷”（Gobbler's Gulch）之类的，不是吗？是的，那种东西。好的。
Some of the scouts say to Custer, hold on. Just hold on a second before you rush in. Just have a quick think. It's a very big village are you sure you want to do this this guy mitch boyer says it and custer is you know i've got this you know i know what i'm doing there's also a very enigmatic scout isn't there who i think was along with bloody knife custer's favorite charlie reynolds who was known as lonesome charlie yeah because he was always on his own.
一些侦察兵对卡斯特说，等等。在冲进去之前等一下。稍微想一想。这是一个非常大的村庄，你确定要这样做吗？这个叫米奇·博耶的家伙说了，卡斯特说，你知道，我有把握，你知道，我知道我在做什么。还有一个非常神秘的侦察兵，不是吗？我想他和“血腥刀”一起，是卡斯特最喜欢的查理·雷诺兹（Charlie Reynolds），他被称为“孤独的查理”（Lonesome Charlie），是的，因为他总是独自一人。
And he'd been born a gentleman and he confessed this to Libby Custer and then got embarrassed about it and didn't say anything. So very taciturn, very solitary. And he says, it's the biggest bunch of Indians I've ever seen. He's nervous. Yeah. You see, I don't think Custer is. I think he has such self-confidence, but also confidence in the US Army against Native Americans.
他出生时是个绅士，他向利比·卡斯特（Libby Custer）承认了这一点，然后对此感到尴尬，什么也没说。所以非常沉默寡言，非常孤独。他说，这是我见过的最大的一群印第安人。他很紧张。是的。你看，我不认为卡斯特是。我认为他有这样的自信，但也对美国陆军对抗美洲原住民有信心。
He's got confidence in himself, hasn't he? It does. I think the combination of those two things, enormous self-confidence in battle, but also it just doesn't enter his head. They're savages. That they could possibly be beaten. Seventh Cavalry are the representatives of industrial civilization. Yeah, exactly. Exactly. I think it's that racial arrogance that we talked about. It's kind of Isla Anduano in the British context. Totally is. It's the British in South Africa or something. So just before midday,
他对自己有信心，不是吗？确实。我认为这两者的结合，在战斗中巨大的自信，但也只是没有进入他的脑海。他们是野蛮人。他们怎么可能被打败。第七骑兵团是工业文明的代表。是的，完全正确。完全正确。我认为这就是我们谈到的种族傲慢。这在英国背景下有点像伊散德尔瓦纳（Isandlwana）。完全是。这是英国人在南非之类的。所以就在中午之前，
about 1145, they start down the divide between the creek and the Little Big Horn River, the Seventh Cavalry. And after about half a mile, Custer calls the two very disputatious officers that he has with him, Major Reno and Captain Benteen. And he says, right, we're going to divide up now because we obviously cannot allow anyone to get away. The last thing we want is to lose Sitting Bull, lose Crazy Horse, whoever, because they've scattered. And this remains his consideration totally so not oh my god there are you know thousands and thousands we'd better concentrate our force it's still we need to divide our forces so that we can cast as wide a net as possible even though his forces i mean his force is going to be massively outnumbered but he divides it up into four parts first of all
大约11点45分，他们开始沿着小溪和小大角河之间的分水岭走，第七骑兵团。走了大约半英里后，卡斯特叫来了他身边的两位非常有争议的军官，雷诺少校和本廷（Benteen）上尉。他说，好了，我们要分开了，因为我们显然不能允许任何人逃脱。我们最不想做的就是失去坐牛，失去疯马，无论谁，因为他们散开了。这仍然是他的考虑，完全不是，哦，天哪，有成千上万的人，我们最好集中我们的力量，仍然是我们必须分散我们的力量，以便我们可以撒下尽可能大的网，即使他的部队，我的意思是他的部队人数将大大少于对方，但他把它分成了四个部分，首先
there is going to be a group of about 130 men with the pack train with the mules and stuff and they're in the rear and they're already starting to fall behind at this point they are exactly so forget them they're being too slow leave them the rest will be divided into three parts about 175 men will be with major reno about 115 men will be with captain bentine and about 200 or 220 men will be with custer and custer says reno and i will take our two groups down this creek to the little bighorn bentine i want you to go and sort of scout off to the left i mean it seems pretty clear. Benteen claims, because he hated Custer, he said, Custer was doing this to get me out of action. He didn't want me to have any of the glory. Custer never liked me and I never liked him. What a bad man
将有一组大约130人带着驮运队和骡子之类的东西，他们在后面，此时他们已经开始落后了，他们正是如此，所以忘了他们，他们太慢了，留下他们，其余的将分为三个部分，大约175人将和雷诺少校在一起，大约115人将和本廷上尉在一起，大约200或220人将和卡斯特在一起，卡斯特说雷诺和我将带我们的两组人沿着这条小溪去小大角河，本廷，我要你去向左侦察，我的意思是这看起来很清楚。本廷声称，因为他讨厌卡斯特，他说，卡斯特这样做是为了让我离开战斗。他不想让我获得任何荣耀。卡斯特从不喜欢我，我也不喜欢他。多坏的人啊
Custer was. I don't think that's right at all. I think clearly what Custer is doing is he wants Benteen to be off to the left so that if the natives try to escape to the sort of southwest, Bentin will be there to round them up. So that Bentin will sort of not quite encircle them, but he'll be kind of lurking in that area, sweeping them up. Yeah, kind of blocking off their flank. Exactly. Meanwhile, he and Reno are going to go down to the river or thereabouts,
卡斯特。我不认为那是对的。我认为很明显卡斯特在做的是他希望本廷在左边，这样如果当地人试图逃向西南方向，本廷就会在那里把他们围起来。这样本廷就不会完全包围他们，但他会潜伏在那个区域，把他们扫荡起来。是的，有点像封锁他们的侧翼。完全正确。与此同时，他和雷诺将去河边或附近，
and then he will make his dispositions when he sees the village and whatnot. Now, at that point, a crow says to Custer, hold on, do not divide your men. There are too many of the enemy for us, even if we stay together. If you're going to fight, you must keep us all together. And Custer snaps again at him and says, you do the scouting, I do the fighting. And there's this story again. Is it one of you do the scouting, I do the fighting.
然后当他看到村庄之类的东西时，他会做出部署。现在，在那一点上，一个克罗族人对卡斯特说，等等，不要分散你的部下。敌人的数量太多了，即使我们待在一起。如果你要战斗，你必须让我们所有人待在一起。卡斯特又对他厉声说，你负责侦察，我负责战斗。又有了这个故事。是其中一个你负责侦察，我负责战斗。
And there's this story again. Is it one of the folk myths, Tom, that springs up? I like to think not. That the crow starts painting his face. Custer says, why are you painting your face? And the crow says, it's actually too good to be true, isn't it? Because the crow says, you and I are going home today and by a trail that is strange to us both.
又有了这个故事。这是民间神话之一吗，汤姆，它冒出来了？我希望不是。克罗族人开始在脸上涂颜料。卡斯特说，你为什么要涂脸？克罗族人说，这太好得令人难以置信了，不是吗？因为克罗族人说，你和我今天都要回家，走一条对我们俩来说都很陌生的路。
But Custer's soldiers don't think that. Yeah, they're full of fun, aren't they? Custer's soldiers are in great spirits. And as they move off, they are joking. They will soon be looking at a captured sitting bull. Take him to the centennial. Yeah, they say, can't wait. We'll be back in time for the centennial and we will be able to take Sitting Bull with us as our prisoner.
但卡斯特的士兵不这么想。是的，他们充满乐趣，不是吗？卡斯特的士兵精神饱满。当他们出发时，他们在开玩笑。他们很快就会看着被俘的坐牛。带他去百年博览会。是的，他们说，等不及了。我们会在百年博览会之前赶回来，我们将能够把坐牛作为我们的俘虏带走。
But will they? Let's find out after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
但他们会吗？休息后我们来看看。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们一起主持《娱乐的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. And we are approaching the Battle of the Little Bighorn. And Dominic, should we just approaching the Battle of the Little Bighorn. And Dominic, should we just give a sketch of the strategic situation? It's midday. The 7th Cavalry are some 12, maybe 15 miles from the great Indian village. They are going to approach the village by going down a creek. And that creek will join with the Bighorn River. That's right. And then riding up the Bighorn River, there's this plain. The village is obviously on the plain. And then on the other side of the Bighorn River, there are these bluffs, these kind of raised stretches.
你好，欢迎回到《历史的余味》。我们正在接近小大角河战役。多米尼克，我们应该给战略局势做一个草图吗？现在是中午。第七骑兵团距离伟大的印第安村庄大约12，也许15英里。他们将通过沿着一条小溪走来接近村庄。那条小溪将与大角河汇合。没错。然后沿着大角河骑行，有这片平原。村庄显然在平原上。然后在大角河的另一边，有这些悬崖，这些隆起的延伸部分。
So if you're riding along the riverbank, the village is kind of on your left, on the left-hand side in the distance. And then on the right-hand side are the bluffs, the kind of hills on the right, overlooking the river. So Custer has divided his men up. He's preparing a three-pronged advance, basically. So Custer is going to ride on the right-hand side of the creek. Reno is going to be in the middle and he'll be riding down on the left-hand side of the creek. And then Benteen is going to be on the left and he will be sweeping outwards across the heights that stretch to check that there aren't any villages there, to check that people aren't fleeing, to try and cut them off if they are. And this is the state of play and off they go. And already they are starting to leave the pack animals with the ammunition
所以如果你沿着河岸骑行，村庄就在你的左前方，在远处的左侧。而右侧是悬崖，也就是俯瞰河流的那些山丘。卡斯特已经把他的部下分开了。他基本上是在准备三管齐下的进攻。卡斯特打算沿着小溪的右侧骑行。雷诺将处于中间，他会沿着小溪的左侧向下骑行。而本廷将处于左侧，他将向外扫荡，穿过延伸的高地，以检查那里是否有村庄，检查是否有人在逃跑，如果有人逃跑，就试图切断他们的去路。这就是当时的局势，他们出发了。他们已经开始把装有弹药的驮畜留在后面了，这一点很重要。
behind, which is important. So that's exactly right. But at this point, the four groups of the 7th Cavalry can all see each other. They can indeed. And Custer and Reno are moving together at this point, by the way. They will divide up completely later on. So they are moving at a brisk pace, brisk kind of walk. It's hot.
没错，就是这样。但此时，第7骑兵团的四个小组都能看到彼此。确实如此。顺便说一下，卡斯特和雷诺此时正一起行动。他们稍后会完全分开。所以他们正以轻快的步伐，一种轻快的步行速度前进。天气很热。
It's very hot, in fact. So a lot of men are dropping gear, are taking off their kind of over shirts and things. It's not a day to be wearing buckskin. No, it's definitely not. They see in the distance, they start to see groups of warriors, very small groups who are riding off. Yeah, but it's like approaching a hornet's nest, isn't it? And starting to see the odd hornet drifting around you.
事实上，天气非常热。所以很多士兵都在丢弃装备，脱掉他们的外衣之类的东西。这可不是穿鹿皮衣的日子。不，绝对不是。他们在远处开始看到一群群的战士，非常小的一群群战士正在骑马离开。是的，但这就像接近一个马蜂窝，不是吗？开始看到零星的马蜂在你周围飞来飞去。
Yeah, exactly. And actually, at one point, they say a group of about 50't it and starting to see the odd hornet drifting around you yeah exactly and actually at one point they say group of about 50 who turn and seem to ride back and there's a dust cloud and it's at that point that one of the translators seeing the dust cloud he rides up to a knoll and he looks out and he shouts to custer he says there are your indians running like devils now that's important because custer doesn't want them to run. He really ideally would have loved to attack the following day at dawn because he would have the element of surprise. So at that point, he thinks, okay, if they're running, this is the point now with Tom in which he divides with Reno because he wants to basically spread out as much as possible.
是的，完全正确。事实上，有一次，他们说有一群大约50人，他们转身似乎又骑了回来，扬起了一阵尘土。就在那时，其中一名翻译看到了尘土，他骑上了一个小丘，向外望去，然后对卡斯特大喊，他说，看，你的印第安人像魔鬼一样在逃跑。这很重要，因为卡斯特不想让他们逃跑。他理想的情况是在第二天黎明时分发起攻击，因为那样他就能出其不意。所以在那一刻，他想，好吧，如果他们在逃跑，这就是他与雷诺分兵的时刻，因为他基本上想尽可能地分散开来。
So it's now about 2.30 and he says to Reno, right, you go ahead now on that left-hand side of the river. I'm going to go up higher on the right-hand side. Now, we don't know exactly what he's planning at this point. Is he planning to come back down to support Reno? Is he planning to kind of circle around and attack the village from the other side? I think probably that. Attack the village, yeah. I think the kind of, you know, two jaws closing the other side i think probably that attack the village yeah i think the kind of you know two jaws closing in yeah i think that's very plausible
现在大约是两点半，他对雷诺说，好了，你现在沿着河的左侧前进。我要去右侧更高的地方。现在，我们不知道他此时到底在计划什么。他是否计划回来支援雷诺？他是否计划绕一圈从另一侧攻击村庄？我想大概是那样。攻击村庄，是的。我想那种，你知道，两只钳子合拢，是的，我认为这非常合理。
but he hasn't told reno this no it's not quite clear because obviously it does depend on the the topography and it depends on the state of play with the village yeah so he's not yet able to decide but i'm guessing that would be his hope. Yeah. So at that point, at the point that he makes that decision to split up, the core of the 7th Cavalry is now split into three parts, none of which really knows what the others are planning. Yeah. And also, it's starting to separate because by this point, Benteen is galloping off into rugged terrain quite a long way to the left of the rest of the cavalry. But also because Custer has gone up on the heights, it's harder for him.
但他没有告诉雷诺这一点。不，这不太清楚，因为显然这确实取决于地形，也取决于村庄的局势。是的，所以他还没法决定，但我猜这会是他的希望。是的。所以在那一点上，在他做出分兵决定的那一刻，第7骑兵团的核心现在分成了三部分，没有哪一部分真正知道其他人在计划什么。是的。而且它也开始分散，因为到这个时候，本廷已经向左侧相当远的地方疾驰进入了崎岖的地形，远离了其余的骑兵。但也因为卡斯特上了高地，这对他来说更难了。
And so Reno, who is down by the creek, can advance faster. Yes. So Reno now pushes ahead. Now we talked about Reno before in the last episode. What did they call him? The scouts called him the man with the dark face or something like that didn't they yes because everything always goes wrong and he's miserable and he's a drinker he is undoubtedly drinking yeah I mean he's got his hip flask so as they splash across the ford to get onto that left hand side of the little bighorn
所以，在小溪边的雷诺可以推进得更快。是的。所以雷诺现在向前推进。我们之前在上一集里谈到过雷诺。他们叫他什么来着？侦察兵叫他“黑脸人”之类的，对吧？是的，因为事情总是出错，他很痛苦，而且是个酒鬼。他无疑是在喝酒。是的，我的意思是，他带着他的随身酒壶，所以当他们冲过浅滩到达小大角河的左侧时，
he takes a long draught from his whiskey flask and he snaps at one of his troopers. And from this point on was whenever troopers are being interviewed later on, they'd say, you know, Reno becomes increasingly irascible, erratic, slurring his words. He's feeling the pressure. And it's very, very hot. Yeah. And kind of necking whiskey. And they've been up all night. They've been marching. I mean, when I was out in the bluffs, I wouldn't have done that.
他从威士忌酒壶里猛喝了一大口，然后对他的一个骑兵发火。从这一点开始，每当后来采访骑兵时，他们都会说，雷诺变得越来越暴躁、古怪，说话含糊不清。他感到了压力。而且天气非常非常热。是的。而且一直在喝威士忌。他们整晚都没睡。他们一直在行军。我的意思是，当我在悬崖边时，我可不会那样做。
Well, that's the comparison that hangs over this whole story, isn't it? Between you and Major Reno. So Reno advances. It's just after three o'clock. And three o'clock is about when they reach the Big Horn. Yeah. So the creek joins with the Big Horn. Yeah.
嗯，这就是笼罩在这个故事上的对比，不是吗？在你和雷诺少校之间。所以雷诺推进了。现在刚过三点。三点左右他们到达了大角河。是的。所以小溪与大角河汇合了。是的。
And Reno's men splash across the river, don't they? And there ahead of them is this great expanse of grassland. Yeah. Fringed with trees. Well, so this vast village, which is two miles long, is to the left of the trees that run along the side of the river. Yeah. And then on the far side of the river are the bluffs that Custer is kind of starting to approach. Yes.
雷诺的部下冲过了河，不是吗？在他们面前是一片广阔的草地。是的。边缘有树木。嗯，所以这个两英里长的巨大村庄，就在沿着河边延伸的树木的左侧。是的。然后在河的另一边是卡斯特开始接近的悬崖。是的。
So Reno says to his men, right, ahead is the village. They've been going at a kind of trot. They start to accelerate now into a gallop. They're getting greater speed. And he says to them charge charge at the village this is our chance this is our moment now again one of his privates says he delivered this order and a very slurred voice taking another swig from his flask now this is the first time many of them have done this they are very inexperienced. Well, including, of course, Reno.
所以雷诺对他的部下说，好了，前面就是村庄。他们一直以一种小跑的速度前进。他们现在开始加速到疾驰。他们的速度越来越快。他对他们说，冲锋，向村庄冲锋，这是我们的机会，这是我们的时刻。现在，他的一名列兵又说，他下达这个命令时声音非常含糊，又从酒壶里喝了一口。这是他们中许多人第一次这样做，他们非常缺乏经验。嗯，当然也包括雷诺。
Yeah. But Reno had had this experience of charging in the Civil War and then discovering that he'd been suckered into an ambush. Yeah. And they begin to charge. As they approach, as they come a little bit closer, Reno starts to make out through the dust the extent of this village. Just how vast it is. And it is clear, the seconds go by, they're charging, they're charging, they're galloping. It's there in the distance. And he starts to think, there are hundreds of these teepees. This is a big deal. Now, he had thought probably that they were
是的。但雷诺在内战中有过冲锋的经验，然后发现自己被诱入了一个伏击圈。是的。他们开始冲锋。当他们接近时，当他们走得更近一点时，雷诺开始透过尘土看清这个村庄的规模。它是多么巨大。很明显，随着秒针的流逝，他们在冲锋，他们在冲锋，他们在疾驰。它就在远方。他开始想，有数百个这样的帐篷。这可是一件大事。现在，他可能认为他们
scattering even at this point. Remember what that scout had said? There are Indians running like devils. Yeah. And he sent his scouts to his left to try and round up the ponies as they had done at the Weshita. But I mean, there are so many horses. I mean, just countless numbers of them. Yeah, hundreds and hundreds. So at that point, now 600 yards short of the beginning of the village, which is the Honkpapa teepees. So that is Sitting Bull's people. Sitting Bull's people. Reno clearly loses his confidence in the charge. Well, he doesn't lose his bottle, does he? Because he's still got that.
即使在这一点上也在四散奔逃。还记得那个侦察兵说了什么吗？印第安人像魔鬼一样在逃跑。是的。他派他的侦察兵到左侧去试图围捕小马，就像他们在沃希托所做的那样。但我的意思是，有太多的马了。我的意思是，数不胜数。是的，成百上千。所以在那一点上，现在距离村庄的起点还有600码，那是洪帕帕人的帐篷。所以那是坐牛的人民。坐牛的人民。雷诺显然对冲锋失去了信心。嗯，他并没有失去胆量，对吧？因为他还有那个。
No, he's still got his bottle. But he loses his courage. Yes, he does. He says, okay, halt, slow down, stop. Right. We will actually take the horses into the trees. We will dismount and we will form what's called a skirmish line across the kind of grassland. So there's about 95 troopers. We'll form this line and we will open fire on the village. And just to say that that line, one side is guarded by the river. Yeah.
不，他还有他的酒瓶。但他失去了勇气。是的，他确实失去了。他说，好吧，停下，慢下来，停止。好了。我们实际上要把马带进树林里。我们将下马，我们将组成所谓的散兵线穿过草地。所以大约有95名骑兵。我们将组成这条线，我们将向村庄开火。顺便说一下，那条线，一侧由河流保护。是的。
But the other one is open. Yes, exactly. So it can be outflanked. Now, Dominic, this is the question. Should he have continued to charge? Because Custer would undoubtedly have charged. That's a good question, Tom. I hadn't thought of that.
但另一侧是敞开的。是的，完全正确。所以它可以被侧翼包抄。现在，多米尼克，这是一个问题。他应该继续冲锋吗？因为卡斯特无疑会冲锋。这是一个好问题，汤姆。我没想过这一点。
Custer would have expected him in that situation that he should charge. And it's intriguing that there is a hung papa woman who was interviewed in 1883. And she said that if Reno had carried on, if he had smashed in, if he'd taken them by surprise, because they are taking them by surprise, then perhaps everyone would have been put into flight. And that I think is the great imponderable. I mean, I wouldn't have done it. I would have turned tail. No question about that. You'd have panicked. But I think Custer would have done it. And it may be that it's a failure of Custer's generalship. To entrust it to Reno.
卡斯特在那种情况下会期望他冲锋。有趣的是，有一位洪帕帕妇女在1883年接受了采访。她说，如果雷诺继续前进，如果他猛冲进去，如果他出其不意地袭击他们，因为他们确实让他们措手不及，那么也许所有人都会溃逃。我认为这就是那个伟大的不可知因素。我的意思是，我不会那样做。我会掉头逃跑。毫无疑问。你会惊慌失措的。但我认为卡斯特会那样做。这可能是卡斯特指挥上的失败。把任务交给雷诺。
That maybe he should have been on the other side. That's a really good point, Tom. I hadn't thought of that. Because of course, although Reno and his men, if there are fewer than 200 of them against thousands upon thousands of warriors, they're outnumbered. But the sheer shock and momentum. Panic breeds its own momentum, doesn't it? And of course, charging at the women and children would create even more panic. Which is what they wanted.
也许他应该在另一边。这真是一个好观点，汤姆。我没想过这一点。因为当然，虽然雷诺和他的部下，如果他们不到200人对抗成千上万的战士，他们的人数处于劣势。但那种纯粹的冲击力和势头。恐慌会产生它自己的势头，不是吗？当然，向妇女和儿童冲锋会制造更多的恐慌。这正是他们想要的。
Yes. Because the women are right in front of them. Well, here's your answer. It couldn't have gone worse for them than it did. So it might have been worth a try. Yeah. Because actually, the funny thing is, when they dismount and they form this skirmish line and they start aiming their weapons their carbines all the accounts are that at that stage none of them
是的。因为妇女就在他们面前。嗯，这就是你的答案。情况不可能比这更糟了。所以这可能值得一试。是的。因为实际上，有趣的是，当他们下马并组成散兵线，开始瞄准他们的武器，他们的卡宾枪时，所有的记录都显示在那个阶段，他们中没有人
have lost i mean maybe reno has but the others have not lost confidence they are joking and laughing they're exchanging banter about their shooting. There is no sense that they're in a mess at this point. And they're actually firing away very incompetently. They are wasting their bullets because, as you said, the ammunition packs are miles back. They are drinking while they're shooting. Madness. But also, I mean, lots of these people have never, you know, we said, have never fired their carbines before. And now they are, and it seems to be going well. They're having a great time.
失去了信心，我的意思是也许雷诺失去了，但其他人没有。他们在开玩笑，在互相打趣他们的射击。此时他们并没有感到陷入困境。而且他们实际上射击得非常不专业。他们在浪费子弹，因为正如你所说，弹药包在几英里外。他们一边射击一边喝酒。疯狂。而且，我的意思是，这些人中有许多人从来没有，你知道，我们说过，从来没有开过他们的卡宾枪。现在他们开了，而且看起来进展顺利。他们玩得很开心。
And then isn't this the point where it is said some of them turn around and see Custer. Yes. On the far side of the river, up on the heights. And he supposedly takes his hat off and waves it. Yeah. And then rides off. I mean, it's debated, and I've read various accounts about whether it was possible to have seen someone. Reno said he didn't see Custer and denied that anyone could have seen him.
然后，这不就是据说他们中的一些人转身看到卡斯特的那一刻吗？是的。在河的另一边，在高地上。他据说是摘下帽子挥了挥。是的。然后骑马离开了。我的意思是，这有争议，我读过各种关于是否可能看到某人的记录。雷诺说他没有看到卡斯特，并否认任何人能看到他。
But some of them say, I definitely saw Custer waving his hat at us. It's plausible, right? Yeah. It's plausible that he would have seen them and waved his hat to encourage them. Great. They're getting stuck in. You know, this is what I want to see. We will never know.
但他们中的一些人说，我绝对看到卡斯特在向我们挥帽子。这很合理，对吧？是的。他看到他们并挥动帽子鼓励他们是很合理的。太棒了。他们正在投入战斗。你知道，这就是我想看到的。我们永远不会知道。
I mean, as with so much of this it's a bit of a mystery now meanwhile people might be wondering well what on earth are the natives doing the answer is that they have actually been having a lovely day in the sunshine you know kind of children playing and all that kind of thing they've heard rumors of troops but they haven't really taken it terribly seriously. And actually, it's only when suddenly a Hunkpapa guy, a kind of village crier, shouts out, they're coming, they're coming, that they're beginning to charge, the charges are coming, that they kind of wake up. And then they hear gunshots, gunfire. Some of the poles of the teepees shatter, splinters flying everywhere.
我的意思是，和这件事的很多方面一样，现在这有点像个谜。与此同时，人们可能想知道，土著们到底在做什么？答案是，他们实际上在阳光下度过了美好的一天，你知道，孩子们在玩耍之类的。他们听到了军队的传言，但并没有太当回事。实际上，只有当一个洪帕帕人，一个村里的传令官突然大喊，他们来了，他们来了，冲锋要来了，他们才开始醒悟。然后他们听到了枪声，炮火声。一些帐篷的杆子破碎了，碎片到处飞。
And women and children get killed, and among them are wives of Gaul. Yeah. Gaul loses two wives and three children in the first volley of gunfire. So suddenly people are running for their weapons. They have to put on their war paint. Now, of course, the war paint is not just for show. They want to have tokens of their power, of their medicine. So they have to get their stuff. They have to get ready, and they're all rushing around.
妇女和儿童被杀，其中有高尔的妻子。是的。高尔在第一轮炮火中失去了两个妻子和三个孩子。所以人们突然跑去拿武器。他们必须涂上战纹。现在，当然，战纹不仅仅是为了展示。他们想要拥有他们力量、他们的“药”的象征。所以他们必须拿到他们的东西。他们必须做好准备，他们都在四处奔跑。
Crazy Horse takes his time, doesn't he, Tom? He really does. Rather than kind of rushing, he communes. He's kind of communing with the spirits, all that kind of stuff. And all his men, his warriors warriors his followers are waiting for him he keeps them waiting then he comes out you know he's as unadorned as ever maybe even more so he's making a point of his simplicity yeah hair is loose you know his signature spots on his face and his lightning bolt harry potter style lightning bolt damage yeah. And then he gets on his horse and the cry starts to go up first among his men. And then throughout the entire expanse of the village, crazy horse is coming and crazy horse is coming. Yeah. What a moment. Now, by this point, some of the warriors have already
疯马花了一些时间，不是吗，汤姆？他确实是。与其说是匆忙，不如说是在交流。他是在与灵魂交流，所有那类事情。他所有的部下，他的战士，他的追随者都在等他。他让他们等着，然后他出来了，你知道，他一如既往地朴素，甚至可能更朴素。他在强调他的简单。是的，头发散乱，你知道，他脸上的标志性斑点，还有哈利波特风格的闪电伤疤。是的。然后他上了马，呼喊声开始在他的人中响起。然后在整个村庄的范围内，疯马来了，疯马来了。是的。多么伟大的时刻。现在，到这个时候，一些战士已经
charged at Reno's soldiers. Some people estimate as many as 500 had charged out of the camp. And actually, Reno's soldiers, just standing there, still drinking and thinking this is a great lark. Like a duck shoot. Kind of fire at them and actually repulsed them, drove them back, that first wave. Because at this point, I think they've only lost one person, haven't they? And he's just been wounded. Yeah. At this point, they still have this sense of invulnerability.
向雷诺的士兵冲锋了。有人估计多达500人从营地冲了出来。实际上，雷诺的士兵只是站在那里，还在喝酒，认为这是一种伟大的恶作剧。就像打鸭子一样。向他们开火，实际上击退了他们，击退了第一波进攻。因为在这一点上，我想他们只损失了一个人，不是吗？而且他只是受了伤。是的。在这一点上，他们仍然有一种无敌的感觉。
So about 3 30 now yeah so at about this point more people you know come out of that kind of flooding out of the village crazy horse of course among them and reno i think you can argue sensibly tom thinks actually there's only 95 of us there because as you rightly said, they can be outflanked on one side. He says, we should retreat into, all the American books call it the timber. I think in English, in English English, we would call it a copse or a kind of little wood or something. They retreat into the trees.
所以现在大约是3点30分，是的，就在这一点上，更多的人，你知道，从村庄里涌出来，疯马当然也在其中。雷诺，我想你可以理智地争辩，汤姆，他认为实际上我们只有95个人在那里，因为正如你正确指出的，他们可以在一侧被侧翼包抄。他说，我们应该撤退到，所有的美国书都称之为“林地”。我想在英语中，我们会称之为小树林或类似的东西。他们撤退到树林里。
Now, some of Reno's men are baffled by this at this point, because as they say, they've only lost one guy wounded and they are quite worried now that he's drunk a lot. So they retreat into the wood in quite a shambolic, disorganized way. But still all right. I mean, they're still holding the line and they get into the wood and they hold it for about 20 minutes. They do. There are arrows flying into the wood. There are bullets flying into the wood. The question is, could they have held out in that wood? Custer, of course, in his earlier campaigns, I think we talked about in the Yellowstone River campaign, he had held out against far greater- But then he had had people coming to his rescue, I suppose.
现在，雷诺的一些部下在这一点上感到困惑，因为正如他们所说，他们只损失了一个受伤的人，而且他们现在非常担心他喝了很多酒。所以他们以一种相当混乱、无组织的方式撤退到树林里。但仍然还好。我的意思是，他们仍然守住了防线，他们进入树林并守住了大约20分钟。他们确实守住了。有箭射进树林。有子弹射进树林。问题是，他们能在树林里坚持住吗？卡斯特，当然，在他早期的战役中，我想我们谈到过黄石河战役，他曾在远比这更强大的敌人面前坚持住——但那时他有援军，我想。
Yeah. But they don't know that they won't have people coming to their rescue. Right. Ventine could come. Custer could come. Anyway, it's the usual stuff. So individual Lakota are sort of crawling forward rather to set fire to the grass to kind of smoke them out. More and more hours of flying in. Not that long after they've entered the wood, Reno seems to have thought, okay, I'm not going to be able to sustain this.
是的。但他们不知道他们是否会有援军。对。本廷可能会来。卡斯特可能会来。总之，这是通常的情况。所以个别的拉科塔人正在爬行前进，试图点燃草地，把他们熏出来。越来越多的箭射进来。他们进入树林后不久，雷诺似乎认为，好吧，我无法维持这个局面。
We have to get back across the river and maybe up towards where Custer is or something of that ilk. Find a more defensible position, basically. And he says to his men, we need to mount up. Now, from this point onwards, the chronology is a little bit uncertain, the order of events, but I think it seems plausible that it's about that moment. It's the fog of war, Dominic. It is the fog of war. That's very profound, Tom. Thank you. We've had a lot of storm clouds, but not the fog of war. Now we've got the fog. Because he doesn't have a trumpeter, does he? He doesn't. This is the huge problem. So he shouts, he's shouting orders to his men. Of course, in the chaos, not all of them can hear him. And in a very disorganized way,
我们必须回到河对岸，也许朝卡斯特所在的方向或其他类似的地方。基本上找到一个更易守难攻的位置。他对他的部下说，我们需要上马。现在，从这一点开始，时间顺序有点不确定，事件的顺序，但我认为这大约是那一刻，这似乎是合理的。这是战争的迷雾，多米尼克。这是战争的迷雾。这非常深刻，汤姆。谢谢。我们经历了很多风暴，但不是战争的迷雾。现在我们有了迷雾。因为他没有号手，不是吗？他没有。这是一个巨大的问题。所以他大喊，他正在对他的部下大喊命令。当然，在混乱中，并不是所有人都能听到他。而且以一种非常无组织的方式，
some of them stop shooting and start to get on their horses. And of course, that makes them very vulnerable. And it's at that point that a group of warriors under a guy called Iron Hawk seem to have broken into the wood and fired at them kind of at point blank range. And it's at that point that one of those shots hits the scout bloody knife in the head. And effectively, part of his head explodes. So brain, blood and skull. In Reno's face. Yeah.
他们中的一些人停止射击并开始上马。当然，这使他们非常脆弱。就在那一刻，一群在铁鹰领导下的战士似乎冲进了树林，近距离向他们开火。就在那一刻，其中一颗子弹击中了侦察兵“血刀”的头部。实际上，他的一部分头颅爆炸了。所以大脑、血液和头骨。溅在雷诺的脸上。是的。
So Reno is temporarily blinded by and covered in Bloody Knife's brain. And he's already lost it before this, hasn't he? Because he's kind of saying, mount up. Get off your horses. Get back on them. And then Bloody Knife's head explodes all over him. And at that point, he's like, he just goes. off your horses go back on them oh god and then bloody knife's head explodes all over him
所以雷诺暂时被“血刀”的大脑弄瞎了，浑身都是。他在这之前就已经崩溃了，不是吗？因为他一直在说，上马。下马。再上马。然后“血刀”的头在他身上爆炸了。在那一刻，他就像，他只是崩溃了。
and at that point he's like he just goes ahhh he does you've basically done him as Kingsley Amos
在那一刻，他就像，他只是崩溃了。
which is not what I was expecting at all anyway and his hat falls off his straw hat and he just
这完全不是我所预料的。总之，他的帽子掉了，他的草帽，他只是
starts strouting you know run for your lives get out of here scramble the hills yeah it's terrible for your lives. Get out of here. Scram for the hills. Yeah, it's terrible. We've got to get out of here. It's a terrible scene. Yeah. It's a shocking
开始尖叫，你知道，为了你们的生命逃跑吧，离开这里，逃向山丘。是的，这太可怕了。为了你们的生命。离开这里。逃向山丘。是的，这太可怕了。我们必须离开这里。这是一个可怕的场景。是的。这是一个令人震惊的
scene. And everyone panics. Oh, shit. Everybody panics. He's panicked. And somebody literally shouts, every man for himself. It is like something from a film. So the Anpapa woman who was interviewed in 1883, she again is very, very contemptuous of this. So this is the one who said that he should have
场景。每个人都惊慌失措。哦，该死。每个人都惊慌失措。他惊慌失措了。有人真的大喊，每个人自求多福。这就像电影里的东西。所以那位在1883年接受采访的洪帕帕妇女，她再次对此非常、非常蔑视。所以这就是那位说他应该
charged. And she says, you know, this is pathetic. She was disgusted by the conduct of these whites saying that they must have been seized with panic worse than that which seized her own people. And she's speaking as a woman and it's fine for women to run, but she thinks that they... They've behaved in an unmanly manner. Well, they're behaving worse than the women who'd been running in the camp. Yeah. I mean, there was then this utterly chaotic nightmare, it must have been nightmarish, flight. They just are running or riding out of the woods, back to the Ford, sobbing, screaming in total desperation.
冲锋的人。她说，你知道，这太可悲了。她对这些白人的行为感到厌恶，说他们一定是被比她自己的人民所遭受的更严重的恐慌所攫取。她是以一个女人的身份说话的，女人逃跑是可以的，但她认为他们……他们的行为方式不像男人。嗯，他们的行为比营地里逃跑的妇女还要糟糕。是的。我的意思是，随后发生了这种完全混乱的噩梦，那一定是噩梦般的逃亡。他们只是从树林里跑出来或骑马出来，回到浅滩，啜泣、尖叫，陷入彻底的绝望。
And there's a problem with the ford. Yeah. Getting on the other side, there are heights. So one side you can go in, okay, but on the far bank, there are heights. And essentially, there is one quite narrow place where you can climb up onto the other side. And so, of course, everyone starts bunching there. And although over the process of scrabbling, the access point widens, it obviously provides a focus. It's a choke point.
浅滩有问题。是的。到达另一边，那里有高地。所以一边你可以进去，没问题，但在远岸，有高地。基本上，有一个相当狭窄的地方，你可以爬上去到另一边。所以，当然，每个人都开始在那里挤成一团。虽然在攀爬的过程中，接入点变宽了，但它显然提供了一个焦点。这是一个瓶颈。
A choke point for the young papa marksman to take people out. So that's hideous. And meanwhile, people are being left behind and there are some really terrible accounts. Oh, terrible. There's this boy called Black Elk. He's 13 years old, and this is a great moment for him. We talked when we introduced Crazy Horse and Sitting Bull of those rituals of entering manhood, counting coup, scalping, getting your kill, injured, writhing around. Black Elk, who's been riding behind the kind of grown-up warriors, he sees this one guy writhing on the ground and a warrior shouts and says, boy, get off your horse and scalp him. And Black Elk gets down and he starts to scalp this bloke, starts to kind of cut into his hair and his skin. And it doesn't come off easily, does it? Because it's quite closely cropped. No, it doesn't come off easily. Well, also because the guy's still alive. So the guy, he says he began to grind his teeth at him and Black Elk finds this very annoying. So he gets
一个让洪帕帕神枪手消灭人们的瓶颈。所以这太可怕了。与此同时，人们被抛在后面，有一些非常可怕的记录。哦，可怕。有一个叫黑麋鹿的男孩。他13岁，这对他是伟大的时刻。我们在介绍疯马和坐牛时谈到了那些进入成年、计数、剥头皮、获得杀戮、受伤、扭动身体的仪式。黑麋鹿，他一直骑在成年战士后面，他看到那个家伙在地上扭动，一个战士大喊说，男孩，下马去剥他的头皮。黑麋鹿下来，开始剥这个家伙的头皮，开始切入他的头发和皮肤。这不容易剥下来，对吧？因为头发剪得很短。不，不容易剥下来。嗯，也因为那个人还活着。所以那个人，他说他开始对他磨牙，黑麋鹿发现这很烦人。所以他拿出
out his pistol and shoots this bloke in the head and then continues his work of scalping him. I mean, there's another story that Black Elk tells. Again, after he's done this, he joins with a band of warriors again. And there's this soldier who's hidden in a clump of mulberry bushes. And he's trying to escape, going this way and that, trying to find a way out. And the boys are all running behind him, shooting arrows into the bushes. And Black Elk says it was like hunting a rabbit. And they know that he's in there because occasionally they hear him go, ow! He kind of gets hit by an arrow.
他的手枪，朝那个家伙的头开了一枪，然后继续他的剥头皮工作。我的意思是，黑麋鹿还讲了另一个故事。同样，在他做完这些后，他又加入了一群战士。有一个士兵躲在桑树丛里。他试图逃跑，这边走走，那边走走，试图找到出路。男孩们都在他后面跑，向灌木丛射箭。黑麋鹿说这就像猎兔一样。他们知道他在里面，因为偶尔他们听到他发出“哎哟！”的声音。他被箭射中了。
And finally they get bored of this, even though they've been quite enjoying it. And so they set fire to the grass and the bushes, and he comes running out and then they all kill him. So, I mean, that's not a nice way to go. It's pretty terrifying. Yeah. So those men who do get across the river they're scrabbling up the bank it's eight feet high i mean imagine the desperation is just trying to scrabble your way
最后他们厌倦了这一点，尽管他们一直很享受。所以他们点燃了草地和灌木丛，他跑了出来，然后他们杀了他。所以，我的意思是，那不是一个好的死法。这非常可怕。是的。所以那些确实过了河的人，他们正在爬上河岸，有八英尺高。我的意思是，想象一下那种绝望，只是试图爬上去，
up and then it's kind of made of clay so it's kind of bits are coming off and you're sinking backwards and as the blood spills it's going kind of gooey yeah anyway so reno of course is at the top he has led the flight because he's full of panic he gets to the top of this hill which ends up being called reno hill doesn't it and um he looks like someone from apocalypse now or something yeah he's put a bandana on a red bandana his eyes are wild well people say that he's frothing at the mouth yeah and he's kind of running around in a frenzy not knowing where to go yeah yeah i, just terrible. And loads of men,
然后它是由粘土制成的，所以碎片在脱落，你正在向后沉，随着血液流出，它变得黏糊糊的。总之，雷诺当然在顶部，他领导了逃亡，因为他充满了恐慌。他到达了这座山的顶部，最终被称为雷诺山，不是吗？而且，嗯，他看起来像《现代启示录》里的人之类的。是的，他戴着一条头巾，一条红色的头巾，他的眼睛很狂野。嗯，人们说他在口吐白沫。是的，他在疯狂地跑来跑去，不知道该去哪里。是的，是的，我，只是太可怕了。还有很多人，
as soon as they get to the top of the hill, they're crying. They're in a terrible mess. And there's one guy who's actually just two years out of West Point, Second Lieutenant Luther Hare. He did not bring shame on the stars and stripes. He did not. The battle flag of liberty flew over his head.
一旦他们到达山顶，他们就在哭泣。他们陷入了可怕的混乱。有一个人实际上才从西点军校毕业两年，少尉路德·黑尔。他没有给星条旗带来耻辱。他没有。自由的战旗在他头上飘扬。
He did not stain it. He was not necking whiskey. Ken Burns joins us now. Brilliant. Brilliant. If we've got to die, let's die here like men. Don't run off like a pack of whipped curs. You see, in another context, Tom, in the context of the Titanic,
他没有玷污它。他没有在喝威士忌。肯·伯恩斯现在加入了我们。太棒了。太棒了。如果我们必须死，让我们像男人一样死在这里。不要像一群被鞭打的狗一样逃跑。你看，在另一个背景下，汤姆，在泰坦尼克号的背景下，
we would take sentiments like that very seriously. I'm taking it seriously because this is i mean awful awful yeah stuff so many people are dying so what kind of about 80 are left from 150 or something i don't know yeah 120 i mean some of them are dead but some of them are just wounded and so they're all lying out in the river on the banks or on the plane and of course there are warriors whose job it is essentially to mutilate them, not just kill, but to mutilate and torture them. And Reno does not go back. Reno really disgraces himself at this point because some of his men say, we can hear them moaning and crying down below. We should go and try and at least get some of
我们会非常认真地对待这样的情绪。我正在认真对待它，因为这，我的意思是，可怕，可怕，是的，东西。这么多人正在死去，所以大约剩下80人，从150人左右，我不知道。是的，120人，我的意思是他们中的一些人死了，但一些人只是受伤了，所以他们都躺在河里、河岸上或平原上。当然，有战士，他们的工作基本上是肢解他们，不仅仅是杀戮，而是肢解和折磨他们。雷诺没有回去。雷诺在这一点上确实丢尽了脸，因为他的一些部下说，我们能听到他们在下面呻吟和哭泣。我们应该去尝试至少把他们中的一些人救出来。雷诺说，这简直不可思议，如果你那么关心他们，你自己去救。中士怀特后来这样说，这对部下产生了令人沮丧的影响，对吧？因为他们向下看，他们看到了他们的朋友、他们的酒友、他们的战友被肢解。我们之前谈到过“血刀”的命运有一种希腊悲剧的特质。所以他的脸被炸掉了一半，有点像达拉斯的肯尼迪总统。这两个年轻的洪帕帕姐妹，她们发现了这具尸体，她们把头锯了下来。因为他留着辫子，其中一个女孩拿了一条辫子，另一个拿了另一条。
them out. And Reno says it's unbelievably if you care so much about them go do it yourself and sergeant white said afterwards this had a discouraging effect on the men right because they're looking down and they are seeing the mutilation of their friends their drinking buddies their comrades we talked earlier about how there's a quality of greek tragedy about the fate of bloody knife. So his face has been half blown up, a bit like President Kennedy at Dallas. And these two young girls, on Papa Sisters, they find this body and they saw the head off. And because he's got his hair in braids and one of the girls takes one braid and one of them takes the other.
她们带着这个头走到村庄，给妈妈看。看，妈妈，看我们得到了什么。母亲看着那个头，她认出那是“血刀”的，尽管它因为装饰品之类的东西而被毁坏了。她能做到这一点，因为她是他的妹妹，所以小女孩们捡起并割下了她们亲叔叔的头。天哪，所以我的意思是，那非常像埃斯库罗斯，不是吗？是的，确实是。还有关于这个侦察兵以赛亚·多尔曼的其他可怕故事。哦，这是一个令人震惊的故事，汤姆。是的，他是小大角战役中唯一的黑人，我想他是一个获释的奴隶，不是吗？
And they walk with this head up to the village and they show mummy. Look, mummy, look what we've got. And the mother looks at the head and she recognizes it as bloody knives, even though it's been maimed because of the ornaments and stuff. And she can do this because she is his sister and so the little girls have picked up and severed off the head of their own uncle golly so i mean that's very that's very aeschylus isn't it yeah it is and the other terrible stories are told about this scout called isaiah dorman oh this is a shocking story tom yeah he's the only black man in the the battle of little bighorn and i think he's he's a freed slave isn't
他最终和拉科塔人住在一起，他娶了一个拉科塔女人。他娶了一个拉科塔女人，是的。据说他曾经帮过坐牛一个忙，所以战役中发生的事情是，他正在战斗，他的马被射中，翻滚，困住了他，摔断了他的腿，所以他无法逃脱。战士们开始聚集在他周围。其中就有坐牛。据说他曾向坐牛呼喊，说，看，你知道，我要死了。在我死之前，你能给我弄点水吗？坐牛去给他弄了水，给了他，然后走开了。
he who ends up living he married a lakota woman with the lakota he marries a lakota woman yeah and he is said once to have done sitting bull a favor and so what happens in the battle is that he's fighting his horse gets shot rolls traps him it, breaks his leg so he can't escape. And warriors start gathering around him. And among them is Sitting Bull. And he's supposed to have called out to Sitting Bull saying, look, you know, I'm going to die. Could you just get me some water before I die? And Sitting Bull goes and gets him water and gives it to him and then walks off.
但据说坐牛对其他人说，不要杀那个人。他是我的朋友。嗯，这是一个说法，但还有其他同样合理的说法，说他什么也没说。他把可怜的多尔曼留给了聚集在他周围的妇女们去处置。据说他随身带着一个咖啡壶和一个杯子。我不确定他怎么会有那个。总之。
But Sitting Bull is supposed to have said, don't kill that man. He's a friend of mine to some of the others. Well, that is one account, but there are other equally plausible accounts that he doesn't say anything. And he leaves poor Dorman to the ministrations of the women who have gathered around him. And he's supposed to have had a coffee pot and a kind of mug with him. I'm not quite sure how he had that. Anyway.
嗯，卡斯特随身带着牙刷，记得吗？我想那是真的。雷诺带着他的随身酒壶。是的。但妇女们抓住了他，她们把血挤进咖啡壶和杯子里。据说她们射中了他的腿。所以，有点像刺伤了他的腿，用石锤砸他，用刀切开他，非常、非常可怕地折磨他。原因是他被视为叛徒，因为他曾在村子里住过。
Well, Custer's got a toothbrush with him, remember? I suppose that's true. And Reno's got his hip flask. Yeah. But the women get hold of them and they squeeze blood into the coffee pot and mug. They're supposed to have shot his legs. So kind of stabbed his legs, smashed him with stone hammers, cut him open with knives, tortured him really, really horribly. And the reason for this is that he's seen as a traitor because he had lived in the village.
所以他帮过坐牛一个忙，但他应得他所遭受的所有恐怖。这有一个转折，在小大角战役三年后，他的妻子，那个叫“母猫头鹰”的拉科塔女人，出现在一个军事仓库，要求支付他拖欠的工资，他们给了她91美元。是的，他的命运真的非常、非常可怕，不是吗？我的意思是，你实际上饶了我们，这对你来说很不寻常。你饶了我们一些最血腥的细节，可能这样也好。所以雷诺和他的部下在山上惊慌失措。受伤的人被可怕地肢解了，但就在那时，坐牛对其他人说，有更多的士兵来了。我们需要回到村庄，我们
So he'd done Sitting Bull a favour, but he deserved all the horrors that were visited on him. And there's a kind of a twist to this, that three years after the Battle of the Little Bighorn, his wife, the Lakota woman, who was called She-Owl, turned up at a military depot and asked for his back wages, and they gave her $91. Yeah, his fate is really, really horrific, isn't it? I mean, you actually spared us, unusually for you. You spared us some of the goriest details, probably just as well. So Reno and his guys are on the hill in a panic. The injured men have been hideously mutilated, but it's about that point that Sitting Bull says to some of the others, there are more soldiers coming. We need to get back to the village we
应该告诉女人们收拾帐篷，因为我们必须离开，因为有更多的士兵。这当然提出了卡斯特的问题，所以我们应该以谈论这件事来结束，当这一切发生时，当然卡斯特一直在河的另一边。现在卡斯特模糊地对雷诺说，我会支援你，但没人知道那意味着什么，甚至可能他们自己也不知道那意味着什么，因为他们必须观察局势的发展。卡斯特可能正如我们谈到的，他是否会去村庄，在雷诺冲锋时从另一个角度攻击村庄？我想那一定是他的计划。是的。所以在大约三点钟，在雷诺第一次大喊冲锋的那一刻，
should be telling the squaws to pack up the lodges because we're going to have to get away because there are more soldiers and this of course raises the issue of Custer so we should just finish by talking about while this has been going on of course Custer has been on the other side of the river now Custer had said vaguely to Reno I will support you but nobody knows what that means even perhaps they didn't know what it meant because they had to see how the situation developed probably Custer was going to as we talked about was he going to perhaps go down to the village attack the village from another angle while Reno was doing his charge. I think that must have been his plan. Yeah. So at about three o'clock, at the point where Reno shouts charge for the first time,
卡斯特在那一刻似乎第一次真正看清了村庄，已经上了悬崖的高地。和他在一起的一些部下说，他们能看到这个大村庄。卡斯特此时一定很高兴。村庄没有四散奔逃。是的。我的意思是，这将是辉煌的。它就在那里。成千上万的人。
Custer at that point seems to have got his first proper look at the village, to have gone up onto the sort of high ground of the bluffs. And some of his men who were with him say that they could see this big village. Custer must at this point have been delighted. The village isn't scattering. Yeah. I mean, this is going to be brilliant. It's all there. Thousands of them.
他会抓住他们的。他的运气一直很好。卡斯特的运气又一次保持住了。是的。正如卡斯特的众多传记作者之一所说，那是沃希托战役的10倍，甚至可能是100倍。这将是他职业生涯中最伟大的胜利。他的部下欢呼起来。
He'll get them. His luck has held. Custer's luck has held yet again. Yeah. As one account, one of the many biographers of Custer says, it was the Washita times 10, perhaps even times 100. It would be the greatest victory of his career. And his men cheered.
我们知道当他们看到这个村庄的规模时，他们欢呼了。卡斯特实际上说，勒住你们的马。那里会有足够多的人供我们所有人对付。所以他摘下帽子。他挥动帽子。这可能是人们所看到的。所以雷诺的部下在平原上。是的。他对和他在一起的人说，欢呼吧，小伙子们，我们抓住他们了。我们将消灭他们，然后我们将回家去我们的驻地。
We know that they cheered when they saw the size of this village. And Custer actually said, hold your horses in. There will be plenty of them there for all of us. So he takes off his hat. He waves his hat. This may be what people had seen. So Reno's men down on the plane. Yeah. And he says to the men who are up there on the top with him, hurrah boys, we have them. We will finish them up and then we will go home to our station.
现在他可能需要更多的人才能完成这个任务。他需要更多的弹药，不是吗？是的。所以他向下看。在那一刻，雷诺的部下已经下马。他们已经组成了散兵线。他们还没有进行那次惊慌失措的逃向树林，然后又跑回浅滩的奔跑。
Now he needs probably more men to be able to accomplish this. And he needs more ammunition, doesn't he? Yeah. So he's looking down. And at that point, Reno's men have dismounted. They have formed their skirmish line. And they have not yet done their panic-stricken run to the trees and then back across the fort.
所以在那一刻，他认为一切进展顺利。但他需要的是本廷的部下。正如你所说的，汤姆，他需要弹药包。所以首先，他叫了他的兄弟汤姆，他叫了一个叫丹尼尔·卡诺普的中士，他对卡诺普说，回到麦克杜格尔上尉那里，带着驮队，告诉他带上驮队。如果驮队像一直发生的那样从骡子背上掉下来，忘了它，直接过来。如果你在路上看到本廷，告诉他，我们抓住他们了。
So at that point, he thinks all is going well. But what he needs is Benteen's men. And as you said tom he needs the ammunition pack so first of all he gets tom his brother he calls a sergeant called sergeant daniel canope and he says to canope go back to captain mcdougall with the um with the pack train tell him to bring the pack train if the pack train as it's been happening all the time they fall off the backs of the mules forget forget it, just come on. And if you see Bentin on the way, tell him, we've got them.
这是一个大的印第安营地。所以中士出发了。然后卡斯特叫了他的号手。他是一个在记录中经常被描述为约翰·马丁的人。实际上，他的名字是乔瓦尼·马蒂尼。他的英语说得不太好，对吧？不，他不说。所以卡斯特说，
It's a big Indian camp. So off goes the sergeant. And then Custer calls to his trumpeter. He is a guy who's often described in the accounts as being John Martin. Actually, his name is Giovanni Martini. Doesn't speak very good English, does he? No, he doesn't. And so Custer says,
骑马去找本廷，找到本廷，告诉他这是一个大村庄，快点，带上你能带的所有弹药包。但因为乔瓦尼·马蒂尼英语说得不好，
ride to Bentin, get Bentin, tell him it's a big village, be quick, and bring all the ammunition packs you can. But because Giovanni Martini does not speak good English,
卡斯特的副官威廉·库克把信息写了下来，这就是我们得到它的方式。你知道，这是在小大角战役中总是被拿出来的来源。你会看到它的照片。这是战役的伟大遗物。这些话，本廷，快来，大村庄，快点，带上包，W.W.库克，那是副官的名字。
Custer's adjutant, William Cook, writes the message down, which is how we have it. You know, it's the source that is always brought out with the Battle of the Big Horn. You'll see photos of it. It's the source that is always brought out with the Battle of the Big Horn. You'll see photos of it. It's the great relic of the battle. These words, Benteen, come on, big village, be quick, bring packs, W.W. Cook, that's the name of the adjutant.
卡斯特的副官威廉·库克写下了这条信息，这就是我们现在拥有它的原因。你知道，这是在提到小大角战役时总是会被拿出来的资料。你会看到它的照片。这是在提到小大角战役时总是会被拿出来的资料。你会看到它的照片。它是这场战役中伟大的遗物。这些话是：本廷，快来，大村庄，快点，带上补给包，W.W.库克，这就是那位副官的名字。
Basically, P.S., bring packs. No hint in that of anxiety, of panic, of trepidation, just we need you, we need more bullets. Let's do this. Let's finish the job. So Giovanni Martini, John Martin, as he's called, gets on his horse. He turns around, he spurs his horse and Dominic, as he goes and Custer says, you know, good luck. That is the last time that a white person who survives the battle hears him speak. Yeah. And he turns around and he sees Custer, you know, there he is. He's got his shirt on. He's got his buckskin uniform pants.
基本上，附言，带上弹药包。这其中没有任何焦虑、恐慌或不安的暗示，只是我们需要你，我们需要更多的子弹。让我们开始吧。让我们完成这项工作。于是乔瓦尼·马蒂尼，也就是人们所说的约翰·马丁，骑上了马。他转过身，策马奔腾，多米尼克，当他离开时，卡斯特说，你知道，祝你好运。那是最后一次有幸存的白人听到他说话。是的。他转过身，看到卡斯特，你知道，他就站在那里。他穿着衬衫。他穿着鹿皮制服裤子。
He's got his big hat. He's full of beans, full of excitement. And then Martini rides off and Custer rides off. And the question is, what then happens? What happens to Custer? That is the great mystery. And we will resolve that mystery, Tom, in our next episode. Well, I think fair to say we will try to resolve it ah tom don't
他戴着大帽子。他精神饱满，充满兴奋。然后马蒂尼骑马离开了，卡斯特也骑马离开了。问题是，接下来发生了什么？卡斯特发生了什么事？这是一个巨大的谜团。汤姆，我们将在下一集中解开这个谜团。嗯，我觉得公平地说，我们会尝试解开它，啊，汤姆，别
do yourself down don't let the podcast down we will definitely resolve it we will definitely resolve it but this is part of of what is so interesting about this story yeah is that actually there is mystery about it and we do you know we're not averse to mystery and we love a mystery we do love a mystery but we do also love a solution so we will tell you what happens in the rest of the battle in the next episode. Of course, if you want to hear that, why wouldn't you? You'd want to hear that right now, wouldn't you? You want to find out what happens when that guy, the trumpeter, rides out of sight. What happened to Custer?
别看轻自己，别让播客失望，我们一定会解开它的，我们一定会解开它的，但这正是这个故事如此有趣的一部分，是的，实际上它确实存在谜团，你知道我们并不排斥谜团，我们喜欢谜团，我们确实喜欢谜团，但我们也喜欢解决方案，所以我们将在下一集中告诉你们战斗的其余部分发生了什么。当然，如果你想听，为什么不想呢？你现在就想听，不是吗？你想知道当那个号手骑马消失在视线之外时发生了什么。卡斯特发生了什么？
Actually, what happened to Reno on his hill? And where on earth has Bentine got to? And we will explain all next time. You can listen to that right now. You just need to click very quickly, subscribe at therestishistory.com. Not only will you get the episode, but you'll get an absolutely unbelievable, dazzling, some people might say, host of benefits. Thanks very much for listening to this. We'll see you very soon. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde
实际上，雷诺在他的山上发生了什么？本廷到底去哪儿了？我们下次会解释这一切。你现在就可以听那一集。你只需要快速点击，在therestishistory.com订阅。你不仅会得到这一集，还会得到一系列绝对令人难以置信、眼花缭乱的福利。非常感谢收听。我们很快就会再见。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德
and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A
我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《余下的就是娱乐》，这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节
we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes
我们揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集
and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及提前获得现场演出门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。网址是therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。